we learned this tactic from eminem in  eight mile it's using the word but and  this is the concept of a damaging  admission if i was on a date for example  and i was trying to persuade a young  lady back in the day before i was  married i might say something like  listen sometimes i have a temper i can  be short at times i don't have a ton of  time to get dedicated to a relationship  right now because my business is taking  up the majority of my time but i'm  absolutely fantastic in bed the more  negatives i can say in the beginning the  more believable the thing that i say  right afterwards is and so if i own all  of my negatives which is why i love this  because be truthful in the things that  you're saying that are negative and the  more true they are and the more damaging  they are the more believable the thing  that comes after the sentence